what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can help decide what direction
the content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable
future so finishing Green Lantern volume
1 no fear um I was going through a lot
of the Green Lantern stuff I mean I'm
I'm like I'm into to blackest KN right
now in terms of reading blackest Knight
is amazing oh my God that story is so
good Sinestro core war was Stellar I
think Sinestro core war is better but it
they they're Amazing Stories when you
get to that level of Storytelling it's
pretty much just easy to say they're
both amazing I mean you're really
getting into like nuanced differences
but um getting going into to Green
Lantern core recharge of course what
that does is it basically focuses on the
Green Lantern core so like killawog the
new Green Lanterns who are being trained
Guy Gardner Kyle rer John Stewart but it
also kind of ties into the idea of super
boy Prime still being held by the Green
Lanterns and what I initially thought
about doing was just kind of saying hey
here's what happened to Super Boy primee
yada Yad y but then I also kind of
realized realiz that in DC there are
like intrinsically great stories or
stories that just kind of need to be
told and an Infinite Crisis is a story
that I've wanted to tell and so what
we're going to do in this video is we're
going to run over countdown to Infinite
Crisis now what countdown to Infinite
Crisis did is it was basically like a an
85 page one shot and it set the seeds
for a lot of stories that were coming
after project omac the Rand thanagar War
villains United and I don't remember the
last one I feel like the last one is the
most important one but the fact remains
here that it basically kind of set the
stage for for a handful of stories here
and there and it went forward with the
idea of basically telling us here are
the the events that led to the start of
Infinite Crisis here's how it all kind
of uh kind of came together in a way
that that basically made something a
little more cohesive day of Vengeance
that's the last one there we go I
couldn't I couldn't remember that last
title for the life of me but this story
almost focuses exclusively on on Blue
Beetle but it's done in a way that makes
sense now for those of you guys who were
reading uh Justice League versus Suicide
Squad and you had a particular interest
in like Maxwell Lord and you were trying
to figure out about his character where
he basically kind of uh became a major
villain what the story does is answer
those questions I mean well it really
kind of lays the groundw for answering
those questions but super boy Prime and
Company don't really show up until like
Infinite Crisis but again this kind of
sets the stage for things that that go
on and so we might be kind of picky and
choosy based on you know what miniseries
we do we'll probably just stick with
only a couple of them and then we'll
just jump directly into Infinite Crisis
but what this does is it initially just
kind of picks up with Blue Beetle making
his way into the headquarters of
Checkmate now because this was a
countdown to Infinite Crisis it really
just kind of followed the trend of Zero
Hour crisis and time in the sense that
Zero Hour crisis and time was actually a
miniseries where instead of going to
issues you know 1 2 3 4 5 six it started
with six and worked its way down to a
zero issue and that's what this little
story does it really just kind of you
know jumps back in time so what we end
up doing here is we basically jump back
to four days ago now of course Ted core
the current version of Lou Beetle of
course hanging out with Barbara Gordon
who again is still paralyzed following
the events of the Killing Joke again is
basically alerted to the idea that
somebody is uh funneling money
somebody's laundering money through
through Ted cord's company the issue
with this is that it basically kind of
uh is is effectively bankrupting Ted
cord and so of course this kind of leads
him on a marry Chase where he's trying
to figure out what's going on but again
it kind of sets the stage because keep
in mind Infinite Crisis was built as
like the 20th anniversary of crisis on
foot Earth it was one of those things
where it's like if you read any story
you got to read this one and so
countdown was basically designed to
introduce new readers so we get this
sort of tour so we basically transition
over to uh to booster goal now a lot of
this comes out of identity crisis and
identity crisis basically dealt with a
pretty severe situation with a woman
named Sue dney in order to keep it
familyfriendly we're not going to go t
too deep into it but comic storan does
have a video on it suffice it to say the
the incident basically involved sexual
assault will'll leave it there but in
response the memories of a lot of
superheroes of almost the entire Justice
League were basically wiped and so what
this did is it basically created a rift
with regards to a lot of the different
members creating trust issues among them
but what Blue Beetle does is he kind of
gives us this little bit of a roller
coaster in terms of how he viewed
himself s alongside Booster Gold because
when Booster Gold and Blue Beetle came
on they were part of Justice League
International and again Justice League
International was the reworked Justice
League team following crisis on defended
Ur remember after uh after crisis was
over there was no like main Justice
League there was no Batman Superman
Wonder Woman The Flash Green Lantern so
on there there was no justice league
team like that instead it was just the
unsellables I mean I hate to use that
term but it was basically the characters
that couldn't hold a book on their own
but it was a way for DC to basically
treat the Justice League like a
revolving door introduce new superheroes
and people would normally never read
give them some exposure and then turn
around and give them their own solo
series if they proved to be popular the
funny thing about this was that Blue
Beetle was basically I guess really Blue
Beetle and Booster Gold were kind of
like the one two punch of comedy on the
team and so that's one of the reasons
why a lot of people really loved the two
of them together because it is kind of
went together like like you know peanut
butter and jelly I mean they were just
they were they were great in terms of
how they functioned with one another the
problem is that after the events of
identity crisis Booster Gold had
basically walked away from being a
superhero he said I can't really do this
anymore well the problem was that all
the gimmicks all the money all the the
draw and the Pizzaz that went with him
being Booster Gold basically went along
with it and so he was for all intense
and purposes completely broke now there
were instances where he tried to kind of
get back on his feet and that's really
what happens here you know Booster Gold
draws the attention of Blue Beetle when
Booster Gold basically you know draws
300 bucks out of an ATM machine using
you know money that that Blue Beetle has
of course Blue Beetle says hey look
we're kind of broke here you know we're
running on fumes in terms of cash but
Blue Beetle also says look somebody's
embezzling money somebody's laundering
money through my company and if there's
any one person that would be most likely
to do this it would be Maxwell Lord now
keep in mind Maxwell Lord was basically
kind of kind of brought in with regards
to Justice League International as a guy
that effectively stole leadership away
from Batman I mean he really just kind
of hijacked the team but it was really
cool because Maxwell Lord was kind of a
one of these characters of DC was trying
to sort out they were trying to figure
out what direction they were going to
take him in and they struggled time and
time again because Maxwell Lord was not
inherently interesting but what this
does is kind of turn take his character
and turn him on his head again now of
course getting with Maxwell Lord meeting
with Maxwell Lord the the meeting is
pretty shortlived in the sense that Lord
basically says look guys your best years
are behind you I mean you guys got to
stop looking at being superheroes you
guys got to basically just kind of look
at the future and see what direction you
want your lives to go in well there's
really no answers to be had here and so
what ends up happening is uh is booster
go I'm sorry Blue Beetle basically turns
his attention to Bruce Wayne and that's
really what's going to happen in the
story Blue Beetle is going to go from
Justice League member to Justice League
member telling them what's going on and
none of them are really going to take
him seriously keep in mind that when it
came to Booster Gold and when it came to
to Blue Beetle they were playing second
I mean when people thought of the
Justice League when they thought of the
world's greatest superheroes they didn't
think of Ted cord you know they didn't
think of Blue Beetle they didn't think
of Booster Gold I don't mean in terms of
fans I mean in terms of just Society in
the DC Universe and so because of that
you know they thought of you know Batman
and so on and so forth and so you know
Ted cord I guess Blue Beetle Booster
Gold they were background guys they were
second second rate guys and even the
Justice League looked at them that way
to a degree however speaking with Batman
and basically saying hey look you know
somebody's doing something I mean
there's information that's going on
rumors about Dr Light so on and so forth
again all of that tying into identity
crisis Batman really kind of blows them
off but what we end up finding out is
that because of the events of identity
crisis Batman had basically created this
sort of autonomous system called brother
eye and what brother eye was designed to
do was basically monitor the planet
Earth I mean really kind of be one of
these you know Batman's eye in the sky
so to speak to kind of make the earth I
guess a safer place now again we're
going to find out later on in this video
how it can be used for nefarious
purposes but again jumping back over to
to Blue Beetle you know in the present
moment right now investigating really
the the headquarters of checkm he's
coming AC Ross all these different files
belonging to Batman Superman you know
the the Green Lantern H Jordan keep in
mind this comes after Green Lantern
rebirth you know investigating the Flash
and so on and so forth and there's all
these files all these these dossier you
know on them and what these profiles
basically do is they list their secret
identities their strengths their
weaknesses all this information so for
those of you guys who read like Tower of
Babel where Batman was keeping detailed
files on how to defeat the individual
members of the Justice League imagine
that information but expanded to include
almost the entirety of the superhero
Community or at least the most dominent
members as well as the various
organizations that exist out there proe
Tech star laabs so on and so forth and
so again because of this what ends up
happening is we actually find out that
cord uh one of the one of the I guess
warehouses that was owned by Ted cord
had basically been raided it had stored
several hundred pounds of kryptonite and
again this was a major issue just simply
because of the fact that if a person got
a hold of this Kryptonite they could use
it for any number of reasons on super
boy Connor Kent because remember
following the death of Superman there
was you know Connor Kent during the
reign of the Superman he was a hold over
he was maintained by DC Comics he's
still around and he actually has a
really badass moment in Infinite Crisis
when he fights Super Boy Prime it's
pretty amazing I love that fight but
what uh what Blue Beetle does is he kind
of reaches out to Oracle says you know
we need to call everybody in we need to
find out who jacked this Kryptonite so
we've got you know we've got Dr Fate we
got Powergirl hot girls so on and so
forth but again what this does is
highlight the lack of trust between
these different members of the Justice
League team and so because of that a lot
of individuals kind of look at Blue
Beetle and say look we're just kind of
doing this as a favor but honestly man
there's really nothing to go on here
you're kind of wasting your time a lot
of them don't really take him seriously
and you know one by one slowly but
surely they all sort of begin to bail
out now of course how Jordan appears
before Blue Beetle and says hey look my
Ring's picking up some very Trace some
very faint signatures of radiation but
what this tells us is that whoever it
was that took this Kryptonite did so
with stealth in mind that if some of the
world's greatest superheroes power girl
with all her different abilities
Starfire with all her different
abilities Dr Fate in the realm of magic
if all these different individuals
cannot find any real trace of evidence
to indicate who it was that took the
cryptonight or where well then suddenly
Blue Beetle begins to lose credibility
he's the boy who cried wolf but with how
Jordan on Blue Beetle side and saying
look I'm willing to help you you know
deal with this it it kind of bolsters
the confidence of Blue Beetle it makes
him feel like he's less of a of a second
Stringer and makes him feel like he has
more of a place where at least somebody
out there is taking him seriously now of
course when the questions asked what
happened to this Kryptonite and where
did it go Superman makes his appearance
and that's one of the coolest things
about this because Blue Beetle looks at
this looks at Superman and says every
time I see him him it's the first time
every time I see him no matter when I
see him no matter where I see him no
matter how many times I've seen him
before every time is the first time his
authority the stance that he has the
fact that he's so large the confidence
that he exudes you know it really makes
Ted cord kind of feel insignificant but
the fact that Superman is speaking to
him and taking time to talk to him makes
him feel important so really is one of
these funny little Moments One of These
funny little things in terms of how
different people view the concept of the
character of Superman not only that Ted
cord actually starts tripping over his
words he starts getting nervous his
mouth dries up he doesn't really know
what to say Superman says calm down
relax tell me what's happening now of
course Blue Beetle explains everything
that's going on with regards to the
Kryptonite that vanished Superman takes
this with the utmost concern and says
look if there's 100 pound of kryptonite
running around out there it's you know
for Superman and the various Kryptonite
based individuals out there it might as
well be an atomic bomb and so it's like
that line from the movie Peacemaker I'm
not concerned about the guy who wants 10
nukes I'm concerned about the guy who
only wants one and so because of this is
Superman kind of saying okay look this
deserves a lot of attention of course he
races off but then Blue Beetle is sort
of accosted by these nonsensical
villains and so on and so forth now the
funny thing about this and this is why I
love the story so much is because on the
surface it seems woefully unimportant it
seems totally unimportant in fact it's
almost over in the blink of an eye in
the sense that these guys are basically
chased off by Booster Gold who returns
to help Blue Beetle but we'll actually
find out later on this was extremely
important this was a very significant
moment in the story more so than that
again this basically kind of sets the
seeds for villains United when we find
out that Lex Luther is working alongside
uh Black Adam he's working alongside
Talia al goul he's working alongside Dr
psycho Deathstroke basically creating
this this new team of super villains for
the purpose of carrying out whatever
missions or goals they intend to car
carry out again a lot of this kind of
sets the stage for some of the stories
that are going to be coming out of this
some of the miniseries that lead into
Infinite Crisis but from this point we
jump forward you know a little bit you
know by about a day and a half or so two
and a half days something like that and
we basically pick up with you know Blue
Beetle and Booster Gold sort of going
through and trying to figure out what's
going on the reason for this is because
of the fact that in blue Beetle's mind
if someone was contracted to basically
Rob his Rob his place you know Rob this
Warehouse then money had to have changed
hands and if money changed hands then it
could be traceable because in the wars
of Blue Beetle people don't just change
exchange money using suitcases anymore
it's all done digitally now keep in mind
Blue Beetle is wildly intelligent in
terms of what it ises he's capable of
but he also has a great deal of wealth
to his name and has a lot of resources
at his disposal the problem is that in
the middle of this whole investigation
when Booster Gold steps up to try to you
know get into this computer and Trace
the transactions the whole thing
explodes the whole house is basically
totally destroyed now what this does is
it sends Blue Beetle on a chase to find
out who it was that destroyed this house
and the reason why is because of the
fact that this damage also includes
Booster Gold receiving third degree
burns on 40% of his chest and so at this
point it's really become personal more
so than business related now of course
at this point the the investigations of
Blue Beetle basically lead him to the
rock of Eternity now the rock of
Eternity at least as far as I'm aware
the rock of Eternity is where the wizard
Shazam resides keep in mind Shazam is
basically the wizard that bestowed Billy
Batson with his powers and allowed him
to become you know Captain Marvel or
Shazam or whatever you want to call him
but you know this guy the the powers
that this guy bestowed is the reason why
Billy Batson can shout the word Shazam
and turn into a superhero the issue with
this is that when it comes to the wizard
Shazam he has a great deal of knowledge
on a lot of things that are going on
keep in mind this is all still in the
era where there's only one singular
universe but a lot of this is kept Cloak
and Dagger we don't really know what's
going on the wizard Shazam speaks in a
very cryptic way saying things like
there's a lot unfolding at the moment
there's a lot going on behind the scenes
you know there are a lot of things that
are taking place here you're a man
you're not prepared for what's to come
and then essentially just kind of whisks
him away and calls it a day and that's
that's that's really it here and so
again going through these files and and
doing some some investigations you know
really eight hours until the present day
um in the middle of of Blue Beetle you
know I guess following his being
teleported away of course the ship is
destroyed and what it does is it leads
to him being taken a taken aboard the
Justice League Watchtower now again this
is where he runs into Wonder Woman and
that's the other cool thing about this
is because with the character of Wonder
Woman writers tend to write her in a way
to where she's either a warrior or she's
a woman she's never both the great thing
about this story is that we kind of get
both aspects of her in the sense that
she's very calm she's very welcoming she
has a very warm personality she's not
just like blur Let's Go destroy stuff
like I mean she's not really like that
in this particular story and even Blue
Beetle in the context of the events
comments on that that whenever Wonder
Woman says someone's name when she
speaks to them it's like she knows
everything about your life and what this
is designed to do is kind of build off
the work that's been done with Diana
Prince to kind of remind us that she is
a character who is a warrior in every
sense of the word that she could
probably kill Superman if it came down
to it but in the presence of friends in
the presence of people that she's
familiar with she's a friend she's
someone that you can count on someone
you can rely on and so it's a great way
to give us you know both sides of who
she is in terms of creating a cohesive
character for her the problem with this
is that you know where she basically
says you know hey keep me a breast of
your investigation let me know what's
going on you know keep detailed files it
really seems to be more play than
anything else like yeah sure I believe
you I mean I trust you man it's okay
just you know keep me aware keep me you
know make sure I'm informed that kind of
thing but she doesn't really do anything
to like go with him and help his
investigation this is compounded by the
fact that his Booster Gold is making his
way out of the Justice League Watchtower
he comes across Martian Manhunter Jon
Jones and Jon Jones response is hey look
Wonder Woman said that she may trust you
that she may believe you but she's
really a lot more trusting than she
should be any superhero with their
assult is going to believe that you're
just full of crap that you're just going
on about nonsense and again it's not
really Jon Jones trying to be cruel it's
not him trying to be rude it's him just
kind of running over the fact of the
situation because again Martian
Manhunter is very kind of like hey
here's how things are like I don't have
time to worry about your feelings here
is the fact of the situation and that's
really the Naked Truth The Naked Truth
here is that a majority of the
superheroes out there do not consider a
Blue Beetle to be anyone of any real
serious note and what this is designed
to do is kind of reflect the existing DC
Community right if I go out into a
street and I show people a picture of
Batman I'm going to say who is that
they're going to say well that's Batman
if I show them a picture of Superman
they'll say that's Superman Wonder Woman
The Flash so on and so forth if I show
them a picture of Blue Beetle they're
not going to have a clue who that is I
don't know is that blue guy I have no
idea who that is you know they're not
going to know who he is the fact that
he's obscure to really the the public at
large the non-comic book reading
community at large is a reflection of
how he's viewed by the superhero
Community the superhero Community
doesn't take him seriously he's a small
time guy he's a second Stringer you call
Blue Beetle in when everybody else is
dead when there's no one left to fight
you just bring him off the bench and say
hey man you got to get in there and you
got to put up the good fight you know
people the general public view him the
exact same way now Blue Beetle fans will
hit the roof if you tell them that Blue
Beetle
sucks walk up to a Blue Beetle fan and
say hey I was reading about Blue Beetle
recently and I got to say man that guy
sucks they will freak they will lose
their absolute mind like he's got a
small fan base I think amazing zero we
were talking about this in the Discord
he was like Blue Beetle has a small fan
base but it is a hardcore dedicated fan
base it is it is insane but you know as
he's kind of going through you know back
where his home used to be and he's kind
of going through this this whole uh this
whole issue kind of struggling and and
trying to figure out his place and you
know really asking the question am I
really just going on a wild goose chase
am I just a dog chasing its tail he then
begins to realize that somebody's
watching him and the reason why is
because you know he basically discovered
what amounts to a small little camera or
a small little monitoring device inside
the goggles of his helmet and so what he
does is he races off to Booster Gold
tells him what's going on you know
Booster Gold tries to help of course
with him sustaining injury he can't
really go but Booster Gold basically
collapses from his injuries from the
pain he's experiencing he's put back to
sleep by the nurses and then Blue Beetle
tells the nurse he says hey look you
have to promise me something tell
Booster Gold no matter what happens it's
not his fault that he's the best friend
that Blue Beetle has ever had and so
this basically leads into the ending of
the story and it picks up with Blue
Beetle following or I guess arriving at
Checkmate which really kind of brings us
back to the beginning of the story now
with regards to him going through this
database and going through all this
information what happens is we end up
finding out the hidden hand behind
behind all these things that have been
happening is Maxwell Lord and what ended
up happening is that when Batman created
brother I it was designed really with
like the best intentions or at least the
best intentions in terms of like Batman
right I mean Batman's not like Batman's
not like a like an altruistic guy
Batman's like Batman's all like hey look
I really care about your thoughts and
feelings Batman's pretty far from that
but what ended up happening here is that
the Checkmate organization which was
previously kind of a a branch off of the
US government where it operated on
behalf of the US government and carrying
out or really kind of serving as like a
monitoring arm was relaunched and
retooled by Maxwell Lord for the purpose
of hijacking brother eye and using
Brother ey as a means to monitor
superheroes around the world and so what
Maxwell Lord wanted to do is basically
say hey look there's like n90 you know
with of all the superhero I guess all
the superpowered people out there you
know the 1.9 million people out there
who have powers 95% of them are nuisance
Powers meaning that you know they can
barely use their telekinesis or they can
kind of read surface thoughts or maybe
they can teleport a little bit or
something like that they can't do
anything outrageous but there's the 5%
that can do Insane things who can fly
who are invulnerable who have super
strength super speed you know who are a
credible threat to any country they come
across not just a group of people but a
country and Maxwell Lord's idea is to
basically say we're not going to allow
our world to be ran by people with
superpowers we're going to allow our
world to be ran by humans and we're
going to control superheroes now this is
not Maxwell lore doing this for the
purpose of just saying we really need a
great safe World we're super superheroes
are under control this is a power hungry
Maxwell Lord he's looking to use
Checkmate or really you know use brother
I and project omac as a way to basically
control the world I mean that's really
what this is this is kind of world
domination if you control Superman if
you control Wonder Woman if you control
the Green Lantern The Flash Aquaman so
on and so forth you control the future
of the planet because all you have to do
is send the Justice League into a
country and that country doesn't exist
anymore and so because of that Maxell
Lord basically gives Blue Beetle a
choice he says look you can join me in
this Crusade you can join me in this
task or you can stand against me if you
stand against me you are going to die
now what he also does is he basically uh
deploys one of his omx these super
powerful beings they're designed to
really kind of counter the various
powers of different individuals out
there for those of you guys who are
familiar I don't know very many people
who are but for those of you guys who
are familiar with like the old school
Marvel UK Captain Britain stuff think of
this as like a kind of DC version of the
fury I mean it's not intrinsic in the
sense that like the fury was designed to
counter every single superpower but you
guys understand what I'm saying in the
sense that it was kind of like you know
this this force of of some kind but the
fact remains here that because of the
fact that Blue Beetle chooses not to
Ally himself with Maxwell Lord Maxwell
Lord shoots him in the head just kills
Blue Beetle on the spot and that's the
death of Ted cord now what this does is
it sets the stage for later on down the
line which leads into the events of
Infinite Crisis the reason being is
because the world is becoming a darker
place now on the surface it does not
seem like this has anything to do with
Infinite Crisis and I understand that in
its entirety however the darker nature
of these stories because you'll notice
these stories are dark these stories are
gritty these stories are not designed to
be happy and fluffy they're in stark
contrast to what you're seeing in DC
rebirth right now the nature of the
superhero community in the world at this
moment in DC Comics with regards to this
countdown to Infinite Crisis is the
reason why Super Boy Prime why it is
that Earth 3 Lex Luther and Earth 2
Superman and Lois Lane show up in the
world in the first place is because to
them the world's darker these are not
superheroes these are people who used to
be superheroes but they're basically
villains now there's no real difference
between villains and heroes this sets
the stage for what goes on in the realm
of Infinite Crisis but again all that
will make sense but if you guys are new
here to Comics explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Applause]
[Music]